before Nintendo became Nintendo it was a
card company that began in 1889 by
producing traditional Japanese playing
cards one longtime president Hiroshi
Yamauchi took over the family business
in the 1940s he tried to figure out a
way to extend the company's reach he
secured a partnership with the Walt
Disney Company to start creating western
style playing cards with Disney
characters however by the 1960s people
were no longer interested in playing
cards the Japanese gravitated toward
other Hobbies like arcade games and
bowling in a desperate attempt to stay
afloat Nintendo sold everything
literally everything including a toy
vacuum cleaner gunpei yukoi joined
Nintendo in 1965 when the company wasn't
at all involved in video games
he studied electronics at University and
watched his friends get Plum engineering
jobs straight at his school while he
struggled to land a job in his field he
was adamant that he wouldn't need to
leave Kyoto to do it it just so happened
that Nintendo's headquarters were in
Kyoto
Nintendo was never his first choice or
even his second or third choice but out
of desperation he applied not even to
work as an engineer but as a maintenance
staffer
he was hired by Nintendo in 1965. to
maintain the assembly line machines that
manufactured the playing cards he found
he had a lot of time in his hands and
started playing around in the factory
where he had access to the machinery for
his own Amusement he built an extendable
arm toy that could grip things kinda
like this that caught the attention of
President Yamauchi who called yukoi into
his office yukoi thought he was going to
get shoot out by the big boss but
actually the president was impressed by
his inventiveness he asked him to make a
toy that the company could sell at
Christmas according to the book game
over by David Chef ikoi asked his boss
what should I make yamucci replied
something great
he thought he could turn his extended
arm into a great product
the ultra hand was a simple plastic
zigzag contraption that extended and
contracted like an accordion when you
squeeze the handles together it came
with a set of three balls and stands
which could be used for practice the
ultra hand was a great success
Nintendo's first product ever to sell
more than a million units president
Yamauchi then asked hikoi to work on
more toys he designed the ultra machine
which came out in 1967. the ball shot
out to where the player who tried to hit
it it was a good idea to make a toy
related to baseball considering how
popular the sport is in Japan this was
Nintendo's second product to sell over a
million units he koi devised many more
hits including the Love Tester which
supposedly measured the level of
affection between a couple when they
held hands and touched the device it was
the first Nintendo product to run on
electricity though it was quite
rudimentary the love test was yet
another hit but not everything Nintendo
sold was successful one product nearly
killed the company
in 1973 Nintendo came out with a laser
clay so yukoi had the idea of turning
abandoned bowling alleys into shooting
galleries where people fire at clay
pigeons with light beam guns by then
bowling was on the Wane although this
was a clever idea it was expensive and
the timing was terrible the same year
came out OPEC drastically raised the
price of crude oil and gasoline prices
skyrocketed nobody was in the mood to
spend money on toys
Nintendo plunged 5 billion yen in the
red it narrowly escaped but it did and
then became even stronger the bright
side was that laser be paved the way for
the Beloved duck hunt for the classic
shooter video game released a decade
later
with the exception of laser clay many of
Nintendo's early products were a hit
within Japan but didn't reach any level
of global success until the release of
10 billion in 1980. you had to get the
colored balls into the original position
after they were rotated by two drums
this was Nintendo's response to the
Rubik's Cube for many people around the
world yokoi's 10 billion was the first
time they'd heard of Nintendo as the
company grew bigger its research and
development division split into three
units yokoi was in charge of unit 1
which focused on small handheld Games
The Story Goes that yokoi was sitting on
a bullet train one day when he saw a
board businessman fiddling around with
his calculator that's when he realized
the appeal of a portable gain that
anyone could play anywhere at any time
but he had to convince his boss that
this should be the company's Direction
one day when President yamauchi's
chauffeur was off with the flu yokoi
drove the president to a meeting he took
the opportunity to pitch's idea of
creating a portable gaming device but
president Yamauchi didn't seem all that
interested however as fate would have it
yokoi dropped yamayuchi off at a meeting
where he sat beside the president of the
world's largest manufacturer of
calculators sharp and mentioned the idea
to him things took off from there and
Nintendo decided to give portable games
a shot in 1980 Nintendo released Game
and Watch although Game and Watch would
go through 60 different versions what
remained the same was the distinct
cross-shaped control pad this would
later end up on yokoi's Masterpiece the
Game Boy
but I'm getting ahead of myself we're
still a few years away from the Game Boy
things were looking promising for
Nintendo in the early 80s however
starting in 1983 revenues for video game
makers dropped almost 97 in two years
home video game revenues peaked at
around 3.2 billion in 1983 then fell to
100 million by 1985. the industry-wide
decline was blamed on an oversaturated
Market especially in North America where
there were too many consoles to choose
from president Yamauchi also attributed
the crash to poorly designed games he
felt market leader Atari gave too much
power to third-party developers who
produced rubbish games in his words
atari's ET is widely considered the
worst video game of all time
the video game industry also had to fend
off competition from the rise of
personal computers store owners
questioned whether video games were just
a passing fad that would eventually
flame out
then in 1985 Nintendo released the
family computer also known as the
Nintendo Entertainment System
Yamauchi wanted a simple video game
console and that's exactly what
Nintendo's offered it started running as
soon as you turned it on and if there
was a problem all you had to do was
press the reset button to avoid atari's
mistake of poorly designed games
Nintendo strictly controlled third-party
development it introduced a lockout chip
so that any unauthorized games would be
locked out they couldn't be played the
company also decided that approved video
games would carry the official Nintendo
seal Nintendo managed to win back the
Public's trust and the gaming industry
started to recover by 1989 Nintendo
dominated the market earning two and a
half billion in Revenue a year and
around 70 percent of North America's
video game market share largely thanks
to the stunning success of Super Mario
Bros
ikoi would personally Mentor the game's
designer Shigeru Miyamoto ikoi convinced
him to give Mario superhuman qualities
like the ability to fall from any height
unharmed Super Mario Bros helped
Nintendo wipe out its competitors the
mustachioed plumber with overalls and a
red cap was such a hit that Mario became
Nintendo's official mascot
instead of sitting pretty with the
success of the console Nintendo
reinvented itself further when yokoi
invented his greatest success
the bulky gray brick won the hearts of
the world upon its release in 1989. when
nikoi started to design the Game Boy he
implemented a development philosophy
called lateral thinking with withered
technology which means innovative ideas
can lead to new products using
pre-existing technology as opposed to
cutting-edge technology
yokoi's goal was to build a product that
was inexpensive enough to mass produce
so that it was affordable for consumers
and it also had to be fun of course
Nintendo decided to use a monochrome LCD
screen instead of color because the
battery life lasted longer and it was
easier to see under direct sunlight
which allowed people to enjoy playing
Outdoors it wasn't perfect the screen
had a green tint and the characters were
always very blurry yukoi agonized over
that small screen and at one point was
so stressed that he stopped eating and
was diagnosed with acute malnutrition he
recalled I considered it my biggest
failure at one point I honestly
contemplated suicide
yet what he considered his biggest
failure turned out to be his greatest
success what yokoi didn't realize then
was that people are okay with
imperfections kids didn't really care
about the specs they just wanted a fun
highly addictive portable game by the
way the big difference between the Game
Boy and Game and Watch is that Game and
Watch could only play one game
whereas you could swap at the cartridges
on the Game Boy and play whatever game
you wished the Game Boy sold a million
units in the U.S in just a few weeks and
would go on to sell nearly 120 million
units in total worldwide
so when you coil left the company in
1996 to start his own gaming company
people were shocked Japanese Executives
tended to stay at one company for life
some speculated that he was fired also
the follow-up to the Game Boy was a
commercial failure the virtual boy was
costly and uncomfortable to wear
yukoi was 55 years old when he started
kodo laboratory which eventually
released a handheld gaming console
called Wonder swan in partnership with
Bandai in order to compete with the Game
Boy but yokoi would never see Wonder
Swan hit the market because tragedy
struck
[Music]
on October 4 1997 he was a passenger in
a car that rear-ended a truck on an
expressway about 200 miles Northwest of
Tokyo when yukoi and the driver a
business associate got out to examine
the damage another car struck them
killing yukoi his associates suffered a
fractured rib
Gung pay yokoi was 56 years old
his Tombstone is inscribed with the
dates of his top creations
one reason yokoi was so successful is
that he had a deep understanding of what
people desire if you'd like to
understand the biggest investment Trends
in technology my go-to app is finnimize
and it's free for you to try out with my
custom link finimize gives you a quick
breakdown of daily news with an emphasis
on tech companies and Finance in these
uncertain Economic Times it's important
to stay up to date on the latest news I
like that I can digest the content in
less than 10 minutes a day I especially
enjoy their daily brief and recently
read their brief about how the U.S and
its allies are forming chip making
alliances to stay one step ahead of
China you can also listen to all of
their content which is available in
audio format finimize is packed with
expert analysis from analysts who
previously worked at Goldman Sachs
Barclays and HSBC whether you're new to
investing or you're a professional
investor it's the perfect way to start
your day finimize is free for you to try
if you head to the custom link in my
description or pin comment you'll also
get a massive discount of 40 off your
monthly subscription thanks for watching
for newsthink I'm Cindy Palm